they say truth is stranger than fiction
that those lines are blurred inside the
warehouse it's a sci-fi novel that
weaves a tale of a workplace so bent on
making profits the workers are slowly
transformed into modern-day slaves we
met up with author Rob hard to hear
about his dystopian vision of the future
that may be frightening Lee familiar
creepy basement
beneath the hustle downtown New York
City missus voice I do I do
uh this is my old desk author Bob Hart
shows us his old work digs to make a
point
it was way Messier when I was here no
working at the mysterious bookshop gave
him both value and time it was nice to
be able to go home from work when I was
supposed to go home from work not at
like 9 or 10 o'clock at night and II
took a pay cut from the world of
journalism to do it so by coming here it
was it was a chance to sort of like
exhale a little bit spend time with my
family which again is getting harder and
harder to do under this economy it's a
far cry from the world he creates in the
warehouse a dystopian cyber thriller
where big tech surveillance workers to
increase productivity and profits the
books based on this company called the
cloud yes any particular company out
there totally fictional totally
completely in my head absolutely yeah
I did a ton of research on this and and
really it was reading about how all
these major corporations sort of treat
us like disposable products like we are
the food they eat to grow bigger to peg
it down to any one company I think is
almost dangerous do work places like
that actually exist the way you describe
in the book in large part yeah yeah so
in the warehouse there is a live work
facility it's this company gets so big
that they just build dormitory housing
for their employees so that you work
there but you also live there so you
never really go home anymore and that's
the Foxconn model in Asia hearts world
pumps steroids into current workplace
practices and unravels the consequences
in the book Black Friday is taken to the
extreme I actually covered a woman who
was trampled to death in a Black Friday
opening yeah at a Walmart I'll never
forget it
imagining a world where deadly
confrontations in stores during the
holiday season stoke fear in shoppers at
the end of every Friday after
Thanksgiving you see the footage of
people who are like practically knocking
down doors so they can get twenty or
thirty dollars off on a TV even worse
now companies are making people go into
work on Thanksgiving to start early
which is just really reprehensible he
also explores Big Brother run amok via
our smartphone devices you have an Apple
watch - yeah I bet somewhere in some
computer system there is a map of
everywhere you and I have ever gone
while wearing these and that doesn't
scare you it's terrifying but again I
have it and I wear it because it's cool
and it's fun you know and this is that
trade-off that we make where we're we
sort of surrendered a little bit of our
privacy for convenience it all spawned
from the chance readings of two articles
the first in Mother Jones it was called
I was a warehouse wage slave and she got
a job and a fulfillment center and they
were really running people into the
ground to meet these these insane
standards and yet people are still lined
up around the block for these jobs
because they set up in economically
depressed areas and I remember reading
that and thinking there is a book here
he filed that away until he came across
this New York Times article in 2014
Maria's story kind of put the human face
on it according to the medical examiner
Maria Fernandez died after breathing
gasoline fumes while sleeping in her car
between shifts
Maria worked at three Dunkin Donuts
part-time and it was just this
horrifying story the year that she died
she was struggling to pay five hundred
and fifty dollars a month on a basement
apartment in Newark and that same year
the CEO of Dunkin Donuts made ten
million dollars and at the end of the
day the cost of that compensation was
Maria having to sleep in her car it's
the same toil for heart's character
zhenya and Paxton questioning their
place in an alternate brave new world I
feel like your book is going to
force a lot of questions I think that we
need to start being a lot more proactive
than we have been you know I've made
compromises and I've made bad decisions
but I think that a really good first
step is if we just start thinking a
little bit so you want people haven't
aha moment I could have written a bunch
of articles a bunch of nonfiction
articles about this the thing about
fiction is that it's about empathy you
know it's about sort of being in someone
else's shoes and and understanding
someone else's life it's it's with you
differently it's a way for you to relate
to someone else's story and sort of see
those common and connecting threads and
and so that's why it just felt like a
fiction was the right Avenue for this
you know even before this book was
published
Ron Howard beat out four other bidders
he and his partner
what's his name it's Brian Grazer yeah -
option this for a movie so it is coming
out in the next few years but this was
so interesting at the very beginning of
the book a former president said this I
pity the man who wants to a coat so
cheap that the man or woman who produces
the cloth will starve in the process any
guesses Benjamin Harrison night 1891 huh